The structure of this course will likely
change a bit from semester to semester.
After all, we hope to learn and
improve the course over time.
But there's an overarching structure
that we anticipate staying fairly
consistent.
You'll start the course by really
getting into an intense phase of study
in the field that you're most interested
in within educational technology.
You'll answer some reflective questions.
You'll go out and
find your own resources.
And you'll really develop
a mastery of that topic.
At the end of that stage, you'll be
asked to demonstrate that mastery with
a custom question written just for
you to answer.
To demonstrate that you can
really think in this field,
you can contribute to this community.
Then it's time to propose your project.
You'll work with your mentor
to scope out your plan for
the rest of the semester and decide how
you're going to bring your idea to life.
At this point, you might also
decide to work in a group and
tackle a big problem as a team, instead
of small problems as individuals.
Then it's time to work
on your project and
you'll spend the rest of
the semester working on it and
delivering weekly reports
on how you're progressing.
You'll talk to your mentor a lot during
this phase to get their constant
feedback and evaluate how
the project is coming together.
And then at the end of the semester,
you'll deliver the project, a paper and
a presentation.
So that you can share your ideas,
both with your classmates and
potentially, with the broader
field of educational technology.
The goal is that your
project won't end there.
We hope that this is just
a jumping off point for
something that you'll continue
to work on going forward.